for jamie reed and james hughes
it was a journey into the unknown
for days they traveled through iraq and
syria to reach the front line of the war
against the terrorist group islamic
state
the ex-soldiers were warmly welcomed by
under-resourced kurdish
forces but even getting to the war zone
was fraught with danger
knowing they would be prized targets for
an organization which has recently
beheaded
a spate of western hostages
the in process i'm not gonna lie is
probably one of the most frightening
sort of processes you can go through
paranoia's through the roof because
you get picked up by a guy who doesn't
speak english
so straight away if there's a language
barrier they need to actually do a safe
house for the night because it was dead
we landed pretty much middle of the
night o'clock in the morning lyrical
moments are like look let's go and get
some sleep at the safe house when you
get to the safe house it's
it's not dodgy looking you think
yourself i don't really like this
and then you'll get picked up in the
morning then you start you
start your journey through northern iraq
to the hq
and then you know that in itself is like
nearly a day's worth of journey
you know at any one point man you're
wondering where's this guy taking us
he hasn't told us where he's taking us
nobody's speaking english to us
you know what i mean you've long gone
beyond the point of any decent
civilization you know in the kurdish
mountain regions
cruising around on back roads some of
them are not even roads
and you're kind of thinking at any one
point there is this is
this is the point where we get handed
over this is the point we wouldn't you
know
that that thought is constantly running
through your mind
up until the point of where you get to
the actual hq itself
that's when you sort of think actually
at least i'm in the right place it isn't
in the right hands
these are exclusive pictures that jamie
and james
shot themselves being shown for the
first time
here they're seen at a frontline base on
their first
day with kurdish fighters they are just
600 metres from
is positions on arrival in syria jaime
and james joined a small group of
western non-muslim volunteers
some without any military experience
we've been asked to blur their faces for
security reasons
the group fought alongside the kurds
driven by the desire
to smash the brutality of islamic state
myself and james sort of felt compelled
in a way to do so
um couldn't justify sitting back here in
the uk
watch is pretty much do what they wanted
a lot of innocent people
getting killed out there for no reason
at all and then
the biggest question myself and james
asked us was to be heading off people
putting someone on the hands and knees
and i mean he's
not soldiers we're talking photographers
alan henning aid worker
british putting him on his hands and
knees
he cut his head off i mean
can you really find any justification in
sitting back here and doing nothing
i couldn't some people do want to go
there it's not just us there's a lot of
people
that want to go there there's a lot of
people that want to help the kurdish
people there's a lot of people who want
to put an end to is
i don't think we're that unique in a
sense we're just one of these many
people that happen to go there and
actually do something about it
jamie and james soon settled into their
three-week embed with the kurds
you are like royalty they will treat you
they'll feed you they'll be shy
everything you know they can't give you
enough do i mean
um on the whole in process and
everything like and throughout
you know they're really hospitable and
they're really
glad that you're there and to help the
cause i think one of the main things
that they said to us on that initial in
process this is you know you come here
on your own ecology you know you're a
free
man you can leave whenever you like if
you wake up tomorrow and all of a sudden
decide that it's a mistake you know
we'll we'll make sure that you get back
to herbal safe and that's that
i reckon the only decent observation
point would be them farm you know
the first sort of day we we me and
stealth and james rocked up
we were dead interested to know where
the ice positions were obviously just
it's a massive thing to know where they
are i mean um
so like you know we went out with one of
the um one of the kurdish lads and
two of the americans and were just
showing us the ice positions that were
in front of us
this is no man's land this is a berm
line you know nobody goes beyond this
they don't come beyond this
and straight away from that field it was
like no man's land
a burn line like world war one type
feel about it you know what i mean it
was a lot of it is just dead ground
between us between rpv and their people
he's just dead ground and just a bound
line
and that in its sense was like a needy
feeling
wasn't it it was like um this is maybe
it's not us
we didn't go there thinking this was
gonna be a well-structured
organization everything was gonna be as
well planned as a western
um military unit but i mean
really it was like it was a world war
ones type
setup
you want to go in at night at twilight
yeah like early i was in the morning
just like twilight
twilight in the morning yeah yeah
twilight in the morning we get in
and we set up shopping now with a six
month team of two men observation couple
of
drinking smoking chilling yeah this was
life on the patrol base
trying to help the poorly organized
kurdish fighters
but even with their british army
training the lack of kurdish equipment
made jamie and james feel vulnerable to
kidnap by islamic state
no night vision capabilities no thermal
capabilities be
expected to patrol out into no man's
land
into this dead ground and then just lie
up on a bun line
for the whole night stared and into
pitch black
hoping that nobody else sees you first
because you can't i'll tell you what you
can't see like you see you can't see
andre in front of you
so that in itself was something that i
think it slightly aggravated us because
we just didn't see the sense in it
was like yeah i don't understand if you
know whether it's like an early warning
system or switch if they try and
approach us but
we can't see them and i mean you
literally you wouldn't be able to see
them unless they were 10 meters from you
friends who met on a bodyguard course
jamie reed and james hughes revealed
they had made an astonishing
suicide pact if they faced becoming
hostages
if at any one point we honestly
genuinely felt
that yeah they're coming for us would
it's definitely over
and if we had rounds on us you know and
our weapons on us then the idea was you
keep one for yourself
and a lot of boys do that still yeah
everybody out there is carrying around
for themselves nobody wants to get
captured of is nobody wants to end up
on youtube getting their head cut off
you know nobody wants on him
so for his as harsh as it sounds
probably the better way to go and they
made videos for their families
in case the worst happened i just
more or less said that obviously i love
my family very much
and that in the event that they got this
and obviously the worst it happened
and i want you to know obviously i love
you
and that um you know we went out sort of
doing something that we love and that we
really wanted to do
and done something i feel you know i
know it's hard it's easy for me to say
but don't ever don't
feel down don't feel sorry for it don't
feel down for it
i mean don't love what you've done yeah
it's one of those things you know
really something that we really wanted
to do and if we die doing it then
i suppose there's no no better way to go
is that
just go go hans you're after him go
pokemon get a move on
help him but their last day with the
kurds turned out to be their worst
at one stage they found themselves in an
abandoned village in
unknown territory potentially rigged
with explosives
by the end of the day they feared their
luck was running out
where are the other guys follow me are
you joking me or what
we knew that is were in this area from
the previous contract
this morning they'd been small arms
exchanged all day saw harassing each
other i think
and there's just something about that
might wonder
listen about that day and there's
something about that night there was
pitch black
freezing cold again but the mist was in
so that made things even worse
and um we could see the small
small arms coming in and they wanted us
to push out in like five of us
to go out to this place in the middle of
nowhere
no man's land and um
it was just you know i was just there
felt like it just felt like it just felt
like that was going to be the last night
to know what i mean
all together like i just you know summed
the whole day off you just said yeah
yeah here we go here we go
you know what i mean and it went out the
moment we stepped outside the pb
literally the moment we left the front
gate the round just started
pinging about again and i was like this
is there's so much just not right about
this
wasn't there's just that feeling it was
just not right and then that was the
night
ha adam havala our friend our curd went
down and all and then we were left alone
and there's lightning like this the
lightning strikes more
you know would light up the whole place
and i don't know it's just had a very
eerie feeling
now back in the uk jamie and james have
had to defend themselves against
allegations they went to syria
as mercenaries there was no payment
no payments you know we sold everything
we pretty much had to
fund ourselves while we were out there
get our flights
and ensure that we got home we spent
every last penny
that we had yeah and that's no joke you
know
we'll come back to a lot of debt let's
put it away yeah and their support for
the kurds has cost the ex-soldiers deer
in other ways they now fear reprisals
from is supporters in the uk
the counterterrorism police have got our
houses sort of red flagged
in a sense of if any calls come out of
there if any calls
come up pretty much out of that area
they'll be straight to our house
and we've got panic alarms fitted in
both our houses now
the trolls purposely put out in case of
a said event would happen
after new legislation to crack down on
jihadist fighters returning from iraq
and syria
some had questioned what would happen to
the ex-soldiers on their return
they were not arrested we knew that
there was a risk
that we could be arrested on return
but we've done nothing wrong you know we
don't
you can't to arrest somebody and what
our personal feel was a humanitarian
effort in a sense
you know i mean the kurds are getting
slaughtered piece by piece i also
committing
sheer brutality over there and
for the us the uk and the coalition
government to be supporting these groups
i mean we if we go over there we support
this group we're not you know we go over
there we join this group we help
i'm not doing it for any religious cause
we're not doing it for any ideology
beliefs
you know we have a zero tolerance for
terrorism that's it myself and james is
more
zero tolerance all together for
terrorism
you